BEING WITH US.
SO MUCH MORE TO GET TO.
SARAH, THANK YOU.
TOM, THANK YOU ALL FOR JOINING
US TONIGHT.
>> DEVON AS IS WITH US.
GOOD TO SEE YOU AGAIN, THANKS
FOR BEING WITH US.
LET'S FIRST GET YOUR TAKE ON THE
FIRINGS OF THE DEPUTY FBI
DIRECTOR ANDREW McCABE IN THE
STATEMENT OF THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL.
>> AS YOU KNOW WE HAD THE FBI
UNDER INVESTIGATION BY OUR
COMMITTEE FOR A LONG TIME.
THE FISA ABUSE AND OTHER
MATTERS, SO IT DOESN'T SURPRISE
ME THAT MR. McCABE WENT.
HOWEVER, OUR INVESTIGATION IS
STILL ONGOING.
MR. McCABE STILL OWES US
ANSWERS NO MATTER WHERE HE'S
WORKING AND EVENTUALLY HE'S
GOING TO HAVE TO COME FORWARD
AND PROVIDE THOSE ANSWERS.
>> Sean: ONE OF THE THINGS
HE'S GOING TO HAVE TO FIGHT THE
ANSWERS, BUT I REALLY SEE HE
EVEN SEEM TO IN HIS STATEMENT
IMPLICATE JAMES COMEY.
DID YOU CATCH THAT AS WELL, THAT
HE KNEW ABOUT THE LEAKS IN THE
MEDIA?
>> THAT'S WHY THIS IS BECOMING
SO DIFFICULT.
THERE ARE SO MANY WITNESSES NOW
WHO HAVE TESTIMONY ALL OVER THE
MAP, WHICH IS WHY I THINK YOU
CONTINUE TO SEE THIS CALL FOR
SOMEHOW DOJ AND FBI ARE GOING TO
HAVE TO HAVE SOMEBODY WHO CAN
ACTUALLY INVESTIGATE THEM AND
PUT ALL OF THIS OUT THERE.
WE ARE CONTINUING TO HAVE
PROBLEMS IN CONGRESS JUST
GETTING THE INFORMATION THAT WE
NEED.
THE LATEST EXAMPLE OF THAT,
SEAN, WAS THE TEXT MESSAGES THAT
EMERGED ON FRIDAY NIGHT.
WE DID NOT HAVE THOSE TEXT
MESSAGES AND WE HAD ASKED FOR
THOSE TEXT MESSAGES BACK IN
OCTOBER, NOVEMBER, DECEMBER.
IT'S VERY DIFFICULT FOR CONGRESS
TO GET TO THE BOTTOM OF THIS AND
EVERY DAY WE FIND OUT SOMETHING
NEW.
HOWEVER, I THINK AT THIS POINT
THERE ARE SO MANY CRIMES THAT
HAVE TO BE INVESTIGATED, THEY
NEED TO GET SOMEBODY OVER THERE
WAS GOING TO RUN A THOROUGH
INVESTIGATION AND MAYBE WORK
WITH THE IG YOU WILL NOT COMPORT
DOMINIC REPORT COMES OUT.
>> Sean: DO WE KNOW WHEN WE
ARE FINALLY GETTING THIS REPORT?
I KEEP HEARING ONE FORMER HEAD
OF THE FBI -- FBI OFFICIALS SAY
IT IS PURE TMT.
>> I HAVE NOT SEEN IT.
I HAVE NOT BEEN BRIEFED.
THAT IS REALLY UNDER THE
JURISDICTION OF THE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE AND THE OVERSIGHT
COMMITTEE.
HOWEVER, THEY DO HAVE A LOT OF
CASH AT THE IG DOES HAVE A LOT
OF INFORMATION THAT MY COMMITTEE
IS VERY INTERESTED IN WHEN IT
COMES TO WHAT WE CONTINUE TO
LOOK AT AND CALL IT FISA ABUSE.
>> Sean: JAMES CASTRO HAS BEEN
A LONGTIME FRIEND OF THIS
PROGRAM AND HE ACTUALLY MADE THE
STATEMENT.
FORMER ASSISTANT FBI DIRECTOR,
HIGH-RANKING PEOPLE THROUGHOUT
THE GOVERNMENT HAD A PLOT TO
PROTECT HILLARY CLINTON FROM
BEING INDICTED.
IN YOUR OPINION BASED ON WHAT WE
KNOW AND 18 USC 793 WHICH IS YOU
CANNOT MISS HANDLE CLASSIFIED
INFORMATION, SIMILARLY YOU
CANNOT DESTROY.
AND OF COURSE YOU HAVE
SUBPOENAED EMAILS THAT ARE
DELETED, ACID WASH, BLEACH BIT
BUSTING UP DEVICES WITH HAMMERS.
YOU HAVE ANY DOUBT IN YOUR MIND
THAT THOSE ARE CRIMES?
>> AS YOU KNOW, OUR COMMITTEE
CONTINUES TO LOOK AT CONSPIRACY.
WE ARE LOOKING AT OBSTRUCTION,
WE ARE LOOKING AT MISLEADING
CONGRESS AND ALSO THERE'S THE
STATUTE IN THE CIVIL RIGHTS CODE
THAT INVOLVES I THINK ABUSE OF
POWER AND USING YOUR POSITION TO
GO AFTER SOMEONE PERSONALLY.
GREGG JARRETT, I'VE SEEN ON YOUR
SHOW, HE'S TALKED ABOUT THIS,
THIS PROVISION.
SO THERE'S MANY CRIMES THAT HAVE
TO BE LOOKED AT, BUT I KEEP
REMINDING PEOPLE, CONGRESS
CANNOT PROSECUTE.
ALL WE CAN DO IS MAKE A REFERRAL
TO THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT AND
THEN THE CHALLENGE IS WHO WE ARE
GOING TO REFER IT TO, BECAUSE AS
YOU KNOW, WE DON'T KNOW WHO OVER
THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT IS
INVOLVED IN THIS, WOULD HAVE TO
RECUSE THEMSELVES BECAUSE OF
THEIR INVOLVEMENT AND THEIR
KNOWLEDGE OF WHAT HAPPENED OVER
THE LAST FEW YEARS.
>> Sean: NOW THE PUBLIC --
THIS POLL THAT I REFERRED TO IN
THE LAST SEGMENT ABOUT THE DEEP
STATE IS VERY TELLING.
I WANT TO ASK YOU ABOUT TWO
ISSUES INVOLVING JAMES COMEY.
THE PRESIDENT POINTED OUT A
TESTIMONY THAT JAMES COMEY WAS
UNDER OATH, HAVE YOU EVER BEEN
AN ANONYMOUS SOURCE, OR KNOWN
SOMEONE ELSE TO BE AN ANONYMOUS
SOURCE.
HE SAID NEVER, NO.
DO WE NOW KNOW THAT'S NOT TRUE
WITH THE LEAK THAT WE KNOW HE
WAS INVOLVED IN?
>> YOU BRING UP A VERY VALID
POINT.
SOMEBODY IS LYING.
WE DON'T KNOW WHO, BUT THOSE
STORIES DON'T JIVE.
I'M SURE -- THIS IS ALL OUT
THERE NOW, THEY ARE GOING TO
START TO COVER UP THEIR TRACKS,
THIS IS WHY WE HAVE TO HAVE THEM
BACK IN TO ANSWER THESE
QUESTIONS.
WE STILL HAVE A QUESTIONNAIRE
THAT THEY HAVE NOT RESPONDED TO.
THAT'S UNACCEPTABLE.
WE NEEDED TO KNOW WHEN EXACTLY
DID THEY LEARN THAT THE DOSSIER
WAS PAID FOR BY THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY AND THE HILLARY CLINTON
CAMPAIGN.
>> Sean: WE DO HAVE EVIDENCE
OF WHAT HILLARY CLINTON DID AS
IT RELATES TO THE EMAIL SERVER.
WE DO HAVE EVIDENCE THAT IN FACT
AN EXONERATION WAS WRITTEN
BEFORE AN INVESTIGATION.
WE DO HAVE EVIDENCE THAT HILLARY
FIXED A PRIMARY AND WE DO HAVE
EVIDENCE THAT SHE PAID FOR IF
ONLY DOSSIER FUNNELING MONEY
THROUGH A LAW FIRM AND AT THAT
DOSSIER THAT SHE PAID FOR WAS
THEN USED IT TO GET AND OBTAIN
FISA WARRANT WITH GREAT
OMISSIONS AND LIES ON FOUR
SEPARATE OCCASIONS TO FISA
JUDGES.
AM I WRONG ON ANY OF THAT?
>> NO.
THAT'S EXACTLY RIGHT.
WHAT WE ARE TRYING TO DETERMINE
HERE IS WHO WAS INVOLVED AT THE
FBI AND THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE THAT MADE THESE
DECISIONS TO MOVE FORWARD, NOT
ONLY TO MAKE A DECISION ON WHAT
TO DO WITH THE CLINTON CAMPAIGN,
BUT THAT'S WHAT MR. GAUDI AND
MR. GOODLETT ARE INVESTIGATING
AND THE IG, MR. HOROWITZ.
WE ARE ALSO TRYING TO LOOK AT
WHO MADE THIS DECISION TO OPEN
UP THIS INVESTIGATION AND WHY
WAS IT DONE?
BECAUSE IT DOESN'T APPEAR TO ME
LIKE THEY HAVE ANY CREDIBLE
EVIDENCE TO OPEN UP A
COUNTERINTELLIGENCE
INVESTIGATION.
THAT'S WHAT WE JUST CAN'T HAVE
IN THIS COUNTRY, WHERE YOU HAVE
POLITICAL DIRT THAT'S PAID FOR
BY ONE POLITICAL PARTY AND USED
AGAINST ANOTHER, ESPECIALLY
USING OUR FOREIGN INTELLIGENCE
CAPABILITIES.
IT'S JUST -- IT JUST CAN'T
HAPPEN IN THIS COUNTRY.
>> Sean: IT'S ILLEGAL.
THE COMMENTS SEEM VERY ARROGANT